procediamo belle a tutti ragazzi che
sono paese ci sono 13 27 schiacciavano
staffetta in italia
allora night uno a phinet freddy's è più
il game
mamma mia decisamente curioso andiamo
non so cosa mi posso aspettare da un
phinet freddy's su sua piece però si
chiude 29 ragazzo insegnato io vado
avanti
cambio la camera quando ti sputa crea
ecco invece qualcuno c'è qualcuno come
ben fatto benissimo
arriverà prima o poi qualcuno votiamo
vestito quanto posso uscire no quali bar
dove dona camuno però non c'è nessuno
qua fuori aiuto beh mi fa piacere che
non è statico almeno qualcuno si sta
muovendo attenzione eccolo ragazze
laviamo la porta chiudi bellissimo
bellissimo effetto bene in realtà
dichiara back e non capisco chi sia
questo fa ancora più paura degli altri
occhio ai chiudiamo notte uno scalo non
ci siano altre notti 5 del mattino
ragazzo ce l'abbiamo fatta teoricamente
se apro non ci dovrebbe più essere
perfetto o pd sete aveva aperto mi
entrava ma che figata 6 e il mattino
perfetto nel mentre mi sono spaccato
degli arti in qualche modo però abbiamo
vinto non si sa come c'è un tasto della
vittoria perché parte di breve rimane a
nero lo schermo ci sono morto d'infarto
però allo stesso tempo vinto con tro
controlli poi ritorniamo un attimo
dentro le nostre corde
cioè 1 ma che bello ma fermi 4 fatto
bene sto matita addosso le cose
disegnate il niente male solo perché
devo capire veramente semplicissimo ho
vinto cosa vuoi ok è stato veramente
semplice no qui successo volta questo
livello va bene
ho vinto con la mano stesa tipo superman
però venne non fa niente poco faito
finalmente una fuga dei centri gli ho
fatto saltare qualsiasi cosa che va
benissimo le poco fa i ragazzi sono
sempre stava le proprio fight ragazzi
sono sempre stato difficile la nostra
scheda alle poco faiti non riesco mai a
farle
c'è qualche modo mi sembrano molto più
difficili che gli impossible
e non sto scherzando sta roba larice
l'ho sempre avuta il che è molto strano
visto che sono il maestro degli imposti
moscherini non sappia fare fuoco fight
che teoricamente una bella di semplice
ok questo è molto difficile infatti non
ponevo troppe speranze su di me away g
99 per cento di posti ma per quale
motivo tiriamo le mutande a steve
vediamo cosa succede
quindi questa è una cosa clicca qui mi
sono sganciato raga senza mutande senza
dignità senza niente va bene ci ha messo
un'ora sganciarmi l'elemento bellissimo
se non pensavo si potesse attirare tanta
stima
qual è il più grosso il caso la figura
più grande a è un quiz
ok sto cliccando su figure più grandi
sono uguali questo
[Musica]
io non me l'aspettavo mai non me
l'aspettavo mai mai
non mi aspettavo ma hugh jackman questo
dove del mouse vi ricordate uguale va
bene entra nella scatola questo ho
sempre adorato perché ti basta fare
lettere gli addominali ilardo minali per
entrare dentro la scatola ed entra
schifoso l'aido dai veramente perché
faccio schifo
ok l'importante è esserci riusciti
minigames quale noi stessi e sono tanti
giochi insieme va bene stai falls non
sono bravo e prova a lanciare luke
magari che mi rompe il cose poi io
riesco a scadere bravo luke bravo non
sei stato capace di fare niente neanche
questo che il ragazzo problematico
siamo senza possibile
l'importante è riuscire gol dentro hicks
questa che c'è scritto aspetta carmi
easy for expert people è facilissimo
cassino allucinante io che sono faccio
parte degli enti sotto gli archi e degli
ori youtube account lui mi ha fatto
fuori account di youtube la chiara
saveri ho vinto senza neanche chiedere
le spade in aggiunta all album escape la
polis che per fa venire un po danza mia
vita ma questo è proprio vecchio stile
braulius
mi piace l'intraprendenza di sto ragazzo
ci sa ogni tanto di schiantarsi bravo
puoi farlo più spesso
una sorta di suor trovo mi sta un po
altrove dove lanciare le palle tra cui
la testa di sonic per centrare gli
obiettivi bellini
questo livello è bellissimo joint ora è
più miss school server hanno fatto una
scuola di s lo sapevo questo gioco
avrebbe fatto successo troyer self
lanciati va bene così esami cui bilancio
rock swing in base a quello che ti esce
indici di più cosa fare o non ho capito
il senso ma va bene
non ho capito niente di questo livello
ma l'importante è avere gli iscritti
quindi iscrivetevi al canale grazie uno
spy fu il difficile è da una vita che
non facciano spy può veramente difficile
lo faccio col nonno ciak perché io
ricordo adesso che avevo la mia tecnica
premi juno apple visto che tu non puoi
cambiare direzione a mezz'aria lo puoi
fare coi gente ma rimane comunque un
livello difficile bello
ho preso un mezzo infarto ma va bene
schiva l'assassino spiegami perché c'è
uno che vola perché sto cadendo è perché
c'è un'anguria cosa me ne faccio un
augurio savasta gloria ai ha coltivato e
sono vivo veri che sono io mi son
momento vinto ha vinto ufficialmente non
posso fare di meglio attaccarmi a lui
eccolo non ci sono io non ci sono io che
le gambe moltissimo che ho fatto
bellissimo replay ora come la quant
altro tipo wrestler e poi club in questo
quest'anno anni di epson dividerebbero
veramente la medaglia d'oro suo gioco
corsa a rurale va bene la facciamo in
bici immagino bello sono momento lo
facciamo
c'è una capra
o mi scusi non l'avevo vista stavo
andando veloce miniera abbandonata
restano fuori invece io entro perché
sono trasgressivo le regole mi piace
potter le anche mio figlio perché h più
che mi dispiace non sapevo delle tnt ma
abbiamo un peso in meno da rispettare la
divisione non sarebbe stata non era una
corsa rurale senza l'esplosione nella
diarrea e chi è che ha fatto suo livello
scusate alber hi i'm albert lo stilo
andiamo avanti ora i monster kiss
bellissimo vi ricordate il rimborsato il
ferimento di scendere sta roba
ricordavo fossero con il mezzo no
discendere a piedi nel senso al mezzo a
piedi a piedi e basta
questo come scendo le scale io quando
sono felice bellissimo
la mia vita è fantastica mettete mi
piace al video e scenderò le scale così
promesso soprattutto iscrivetevi al
canale schiacciate con la maledettissima
campanella crunch aveta attiva io lo
vedo vi vedo ma edizione cose amici però
nonno ciak che sembra acciaccato ma in
realtà non lo ha cercato non ho mai
capito però non devi pedalare co sta
succedendo lì cosa sta modi alternativi
per andare in bici però va bene non ho
sei stato fantasy non li vuoi superare
questi a meno che non c'è una salita
articolo ma puoi superarli quella eccolo
che sorpassa che sorpasso
ragazzi questo è un modo per andare in
bici non convenzionale però ve lo
assicuro è molto divertente
ok io sono passati io non c'è fallo sono
stato scorretto non hanno tentano il
sorpasso finale ma non ci riesce
lo stacco proprio noi la chiude è
difficile perché superati non è mai
stato semplice quindi molto bene il gol
a ok così va bene ragazzi c'è questa è
stata geniale avevo giocato solo un
livello così di fare che mira che mira
porco avevano è più difficile di quanto
sembri ragazzi non è non è facile lo
giuro ho ma dai non ci credo ferrari
ti prego vai
tiger woods tiger pozzo rock swing rock
finché siamo siamo su lisi cercando di
fare un pochettino tutto per tornare il
mood è tranquillo perché il rock swing
sono sempre complicate di quanto si
pensi però sei bravo a toccare votato e
verde sul nero ti puoi livello di matrix
sono sicuro che ci sia un livello di
matrix su è più che in qualche modo
perfetto
bravo lo zio sono bravissimo però xing
scoraggino tagliati le mani le gambe va
bene no oggi va benissimo di non far
nomi di ragazzi queste ramblers
per questo domenica mi sono preso un
infarto visto che si possono tirare
mutande i personaggi che è la stessa
cosa di prendere infarciti accende il
tasto iscriviti e la campanella vi vedo
che non l'ha schiacciata e per gli
imputati solo di video era come sempre
ci vediamo a rompersi sono molto
contento di essere ripreso jobs che era
anche su e pinguins che non dovrebbe
esserci a coverciano si trova bene e da
ragazzi
[Musica]